hi there today we'll look at generative
adversarial Nets by Ian J good fellow at
all so this one is another installment
in our series of historical papers that
had great impact Ganz nowadays or
general generative adversarial Nets back
then were sort of this was the starting
shot in a long line of research that is
still continuing today so I remember
when I started my PhD in 2015 Ganz were
just about spiking I remember new rips
or back then nips in 2016 and every
other paper was about Ganz it was there
was also this famous schmidhuber
Goodfellow moment at the tutorial it was
it was a wild time and this is the paper
that started it all and the paper is
quite well written it's very kind of
focused on convincing you that this is a
sound method mathematically that it does
do you know that it doesn't just do wild
things and also it is already quite has
a lot of the it has a lot of sort of the
modern tricks for Gans already sort of
built into it so astounding how how much
foresight there was already in this
paper but of course Gans have come like
a super long way since then and today
we'll just go through the paper and look
at how it looked back then and what this
paper was like so yeah join me in this
if you like it please share it out let
me know in the comments what you think
of historic paper reviews this is not
going to be like in a beginners tutorial
in Gans this is really going to be we'll
go through the paper you see right here
the paper is from 2014 so it would still
be another like two years or so until
Gans really take off from this point on
but the introduction of course was
really important okay
so abstract here we go we propose a
framework for estimating generative
models via an adversarial process in
which we simultaneously train two models
a generative model G that captures the
data distribution and a discriminative
model D that estimates the probability
that a sample came from the training
data rather than G okay this was sort of
a new thing now
I know I know people disagree with this
being a new thing but this was a new
thing and specifically this this was the
first paper that made something like
this really work for data so to have a
discriminator D and the words generator
and discriminator were also introduced
in this paper so you train this D model
which is the discriminator and the D
model basically decides whether or not a
given data point comes from data or
comes from the fake distribution and
then you have a generative model G that
is supposed to just create this data X
rather and then coming from the database
so you want to sample a couple of times
from the data and sometimes you sample
from this model G and then the
discriminator is supposed to decide
whether or not it comes from the dataset
or from your count from your
counterfeiter like from it is generator
G and it's supposed to see it say
whether its data fake so you train the D
model as a simple image classifier so
people already knew how to build image
classifiers this was this was shortly as
you can see before ResNet came on the
scene so people already kind of knew how
to build cnn's build really good image
classifiers and the thought here was
really generative models weren't really
a thing until then so people were in
language models work too vac was kind of
coming up but they were would still be
doing like RN ends using these word to
vac vectors for generating language in
images distant AK generative models
weren't really much of a thing so
you you would do like compositional
models or you would do auto-encoders
which were just either really blurry or
really really are the factory and there
are also approaches like deep belief
networks and so on but they have their
own problems so there wasn't really a
satisfactory way to do image generation
that resulted in here really high
quality images and now here I think the
entire fault and this is not really
spelled out but the entire thought here
is that hey we know how to train really
really good image classifiers right this
has been evident in these since since
alex net so for two years this was
evident how to build really good image
classifiers and the question here is to
say that rather than also building
really good generators can't we like
harness the power of building really
good classifiers
for training and generator right and
this this is this idea right here this
wasn't the one before as you know in
like an autoencoder what you do is you
input a sample into some kind of auto
bottleneck thing whatever and then at
the end you train your output sample to
match the input sample as close as
possible and then in here after you've
trained this this part here is your
generative model and then here in here
you'd input like MCMC sampling or
whatnot and then of course variational
autoencoders came up and so on but still
what you always would do is you would
somehow use the data directly so this is
data in order to train your model so you
would somehow say ah the output here
should probably match the input in some
way or in some at least distributional
way right this this was a new thing as
you can see right here there is no
direct connection between the data and
the generator and I think this this was
the success of this model the fact that
the generator did not it wasn't trained
from the data like you would do if you
were just approaching this problem but
the philosophy here is let's use the
power of discriminative
models which we know how to build in
order to train this generator right so
the generators task now isn't to match
any sort of data point the generators
task is to produce images that the
discriminator would classify as data and
you can do that by simply back
propagating through the discriminator to
the generator okay so I think that's
that's the only thing that's kind of
unstated in this paper the the reasoning
behind why this is new why this might
work but everything else is spelled out
very well in this paper I have to say if
you read through it so the training
procedure for G is to maximize the
probability of D making a mistake
this framework corresponds to a minimax
two-player game so as I said the paper
is very much focused on convincing you
that there's something sound happening
here because at that time if you were to
look at this you'd say something like
there is no way right
you would be like yeah so so I can
understand the motivation here to really
convince people that you know something
something good is happening also on the
on the theoretical side in the spaces
are in the space of arbitrary functions
G and D a unique solution exists with G
recovering the training data
distribution D equals to 1/2 everywhere
in the case where G and D are defined by
multi-layer perceptrons the entire
system can be trained with
backpropagation there is no need for any
mark of canes or unrolled approximate
inference networks during either
training or generation of samples ok so
the point here is that it's much easier
than current methods of producing of
generative models and also it does
something sound now let's jump into the
loss function right here so they say G
and D play the following two-player
minimax game with value function V and
this is you know still understood
until today that it was already like if
this was a pure engineering paper they
could simply build the architecture and
say oh we let these networks fight and
they they are kind of adversarial and
they they pump each other up and so on
and and this here was more much more
into the direction of kind of a a
theoretical reasoning into why something
like this would work of course there is
still a lot of engineering going on to
actually make it work so they they have
there is this value function right here
okay and the value function is the
following so what you have is you have
the log probability of data and you have
one the log 1 minus D of the generated
samples so here you can see and this was
introduced this seems also obvious now
right but you have a prior on what this
is called the noise distribution okay
they have a prior on your input noise to
the generator because the generator is
supposed to come up with very many
different data points and if it is a if
it is a you know non stochastic function
like a neural network then you need some
way to make to produce different images
so there is this prior distribution over
the noise you feed that noise into the
generator the generator will produce an
output you put that into the
discriminator and then this right here
as you can see the discriminator is
trying to maximize this objective so the
discriminator is trying to maximize the
probability of real data and it is
trying to minimize the probability of
fake data okay it is this is simply a
two-way classification problem at the
same time the generator as you can see
is trying to minimize the objective in
fact the order here is quite important
so the generator as you can see is
trying to minimize whatever this here is
so the generator is sort of is trying
to minimize against the best possible
discriminator and so this is one one
observation right here is that the
formulation is always with respect to a
perfect discriminator now we know that
this doesn't work with if you have a
perfect discriminator than generator
cannot catch up because you have
insufficient gradients and so on and
this was already recognized in this
paper as well but the formulation is
with respect to a min Max game and not a
max min game so the other point I want
to make here is that you can see the
discriminator appears in both in both
terms right here
however the generator only appears right
here okay and this this basically means
that the objective for the generator is
only this part here because the other
part is constant so the generator is
just trying to make the discriminator
think that fake data is real so it is
trying to make the discriminator the
class of fake data as small as possible
for the data that it outputs while the
discriminator is trying to make the
class of fake data more than the class
of sorry real data yeah it's trying to
make it it's trying to classify fake
data as fake and real data as real
whereas the generator as only this part
on the right this is I feel this is um
it's quite important um why because
already in this paper they recognize
that this might not be the best
practical objective and for the
generator they can actually exchange
this part here on the right to simply
say we want to so we want to instead of
1 minus D instead of log 1 minus D we
simply want to use minus log D as an
objective for the generator so you can
kind of play around with this and as you
know lots of formulations have played
around with this loss right here and
yeah that's why we have like a billion
billion billion billion gam variations
the
introduce the reasoning behind this so
that there's an intuition right here and
you can see already in practice equation
one may not provide sufficient gradient
for GE to learn well early in learning
when G is poor D can reject samples with
high confidence because they are clearly
different from the training data in this
case this saturates rather than training
G to minimize that we can train G to
maximize log D this objective function
results in the same fixed point for the
dynamic but provides much stronger
gradients in early much stronger
gradients early in learning this is in
contrast to like other papers that
simply say oh we do this and they at
least say it provides the same fixed
point right yeah so again they're trying
to convince you that this is doing
something useful and that this is easier
okay so this strategy is analogous to
other things
training maintain samples from a Markov
chain from one learning step in the next
two order to avoid burning in the Markov
chain in another loop of learning sorry
okay this is from another paper so their
point here is that it's analogous to
other papers that use these markov
chains where you always do one step in
GE and one step in d we alternate
between K steps of optimizing D and one
step of optimizing G because you have
this inner maximization over D and then
the outer maxim is it in the outer
minimization over G so this has already
been around the fact that you kind of
have to have these optimizations in
lockstep but the difference here is you
don't need any sort of like Markov chain
in the inner loop and so on you simply
need back propagation so here's an
illustration of how that might work so
at the beginning here you have your z
space and this is always sampled
uniformly as you can see right here this
is from a prior distribution and through
the mapping so this here is from Z to X
is G so this is the mapping G you can
see that the uniform distribution is now
mapped to something non uniform which
results in the green thing
so G is the Greenline while as this is
data the black dots are data and if you
have a discriminator the discriminator
is supposed to tell you where there's
data and where there's fake data now so
green here is fake now this blue line is
sort of a half-trained discriminator now
you train d right you max maximize d the
discriminator and that gives you this
blue line right here so this this is a
perfect discriminator for these two data
distributions it tells you it's
basically the the ratio of green to
black at each point and now you train
the generator according to this and you
can see that the gradient of the
discriminator yes so the gradient of the
discriminator is in this direction okay
so it's like up this hill and that's why
you want to shift your green curve over
here according to the gradient of the
discriminator note that you know we
first trained the discriminator and now
in the second step we mean we optimize
the generator so now we shift this green
curve over in order to in along the
gradient of the blue curve so it's
important the green curve doesn't see
the black curve ever the generator
doesn't see the data the generator
simply sees that blue curve and it goes
along the gradient of that blue curve of
the discriminator ok and then if you do
this many many steps actually there are
dots right here you will end up with a
discriminator that has no clue what's
where this is 1/2 probability everywhere
because the ratio is the same and you
end up with the probability of data
equal to the probability of the output
generated samples and this can happen if
the generator simply remembers the
training data
but there are a number of things that
counter that for example the generator
is continuous while the training data is
of course a discrete so there is this in
between things right here where there is
no training data in fact you hit a
exactly training data is very very
unlikely but of course you can still you
can still peek at the training data but
also the there I think there are two
things while the generator doesn't
simply remember the training data first
because it doesn't ever see the training
data directly so it can only see it
through the discriminator and second of
all because it is built as these
multi-layer neural networks it doesn't
have the power to just remember this
because as there is kind of this notion
of continuous function so and the these
neural networks are rather smooth
functions often and therefore I think
that is something that helps the
generator avoid remembering the training
data of course there is still this
problem of mode collapse that was really
big in Gantz so even if it doesn't
remember the training data it might
focus on the easiest part of the
training data and forget all other parts
and that was a direct result actually of
this objective so where it was it so
this objective directly led to mode
collapse in some in some form because it
penalizes different errors differently
so of course people have come up with
ways to to solve that okay now here is
the algorithm as you can see this was
already quite it was already quite the
algorithm we use nowadays so for K steps
this is the inner maximization and here
they say that we use K equals 1 so all
this is this is pretty much what we use
today the early days of Gann were still
like how much do I need to discriminator
per generator and so on nowadays
everyone's just using one step here one
step there or even training and jointly
works in some cases so you want to
sample a mini batch of noise samples and
you will sample a mini batch of em
examples from training data generation
so from this data you want to update the
discriminator by ascending it's
stochastic gradient and this is simply
the gradient of the objective and then
after those K steps you're going to
sample another mini batch of noise
samples and update the generator by
descending it's stochastic gradient and
you can see right here already there is
this reduced objective that doesn't
include this because it falls away in
the gradient right and they say the
gradient based updates can use any
standard learning based rule we use
momentum in our experiments very cool so
I believe they already also say that it
is somewhere here it's pretty it's
pretty fun that they say oh in our
generator we only input noise at the
lowest layer this is also something that
if you think that G here is a
multi-layer network so it's kind of a
multi-layer network that outputs an
image right and if you ask yourself if I
have noise how would I input that into
there it's so clear nowadays that you
know we just put it here but this was
not clear at all this was kind of an
invention of this paper because you
could you know put it pretty much at all
layers you could distribute it and so on
you could add some right here it it was
this paper that already established the
fact that we input noise kind of as a
vector at the very beginning and then
just let the neural network produce the
image from that so yeah pretty pretty
cool it's pretty sneaky how many things
are hidden in these initial papers how
many decisions that are made there then
are just taken over and you know this
one I guess turned out to be fairly
fairly good okay so here they go for
some theoretical analysis and the first
they want to convince you that if the
the generator if this all works well
if this if both parties this generator
and the discriminator optimized their
objective to the optimum then the
generator will have captured the data
distribution so the global optimality of
this and they go about convincing you of
that so the first thing that they
convince you of is that if you fix the
generator the optimal discriminator is
this and we've already seen this in this
drawing right here so the optimal
discriminator is simply the ratio of the
data of the likelihood of data versus
the likelihood of the generated data
okay so you train you're always trained
eat this discriminator in the inner loop
and that's simply the consequence of
this of a point wise this is true point
wise therefore it's true over the entire
data distribution in the next thing they
convince you that the global minimum of
the virtual training criterion and this
is the value function this min max game
is achieved if and only if this holds at
that point the training criterion
achieves the value of negative log four
and this again this was already already
here the fact that this has a global
minimum and it is achieved when the
generator matches the data distribution
which is pretty cool so in the proof
it's pretty simple actually they first
say look if this is the case we just
simply plug that in this the
discriminator will be confused so if the
generator exactly captures the data the
discriminator will have no clue what's
going on right because it can't because
they're equal so it must basically
output the probability of 1/2 everywhere
and then your objective becomes a
constant negative log for now if you
then plug that into the other equation
you'll see that the training criterion
ends
being negative log four plus twice the
Jensen Shannon divergence between the
data and the generated distribution and
since this term here is always positive
that means that this thing here can
never be less than negative log four and
therefore the negative log four is the
optimum okay that's it's that the proof
is is pretty cool I have to say to show
that this has the optimum at that place
and the last thing they convinced you of
is that this algorithm actually
converges and the converges is simply
predicated on the fact that if you look
at each of these problems individually
they are convex so like here is convex
and X for every alpha so each of these
are sort of convex problems and then it
will naturally converge to the two their
minimum however in practice adversarial
nets represent a limited family of
distributions via the function and we
optimize the parameters rather than the
distribution itself using a multi-layer
perceptron to define G introduces
multiple critical points in parameter
space however the excellent performance
of the multi-layer perceptrons in
practice suggests that they are a
reasonable model to use despite their
lack of theoretical guarantees so they
say if we could optimize this
probability distribution directly it is
a convex problem and we always converge
but in practice of course we only
optimize the parameters of an MLP or a
CNN and that doesn't always converge but
we have reasonable hopes that it will
converge okay so again it's very much
focused on convincing me that this is
doing something sensible which I hope
now you are convinced so there is a
global optimum point it's when the
generator captures the data distribution
perfectly this is this can be achieved
and we
we'll be achieved if you can optimize
these probability distributions with a
reasonable degree of freedom and the
neural networks provide that reasonable
degree of freedom and you know give us
good hope that in practice it will work
so they apply this to data sets namely M
nest the Toronto phase database and C
410 the generator Nets use the mixture
of rectified linear activations and
sigmoid activation z' while the
discriminator net used maxout
activations that was still a thing
dropout was applied in training and the
discriminator net while our theoretical
framework misused other data yeah while
our theoretical framework permits the
use of dropout and other noise at
intermediate layers of the generator we
used noise as the input to only the
bottom most layer of the generator
Network again this wasn't kind of clear
at the beginning and also the fact that
to leave out dropout and so on in the
generator was I guess they found that
empirically and then there was of course
no way to evaluate these things like how
do we evaluate generative models
nowadays we have these inception
distances and so on but then we estimate
probability of the test set under P on
the regenerated data by fitting a
Gaussian parson window to the samples
generated with G and reporting the
log-likelihood under this distribution
the theta parameter yada-yada results
are reported this method of estimating
the likelihood has somewhat high
variance and does not perform well in
high dimensional spaces but it is the
best method available to our knowledge
advances in generative models that can
sample but not estimate likelihood
directly motivated further research into
into how to evaluate such models they
were absolutely right in this and there
was a lot of research into Europe into
how to evaluate these models however I
it is my opinion that we still have very
very limited methods of evaluating
models like this like we have better
methods but it's yeah it's not really
it's not really satisfactory how it is
right now so you see that these models
these adversarial Nets by the way
they're always called adversarial Nets
right here well I think we call them
like most people would call them
adversarial networks but it's just
interesting to see the nets and also in
the title right it says I think it says
Nets
does it I think it does we'll look at it
after so the T out they outperform these
other models in especially these these
belief networks were kind of popular at
the time and you can see the samples
right here were in no way comparable to
examples that you get from the modern
Ganz but this was already very very very
good especially the emne stand then here
you could ask actually recognize so the
once what the yellow are always from the
training data set they're like the
nearest neighbors of the things on the
left so they want to show that it
doesn't some simply remember the
training data though I'm not so sure
like this seems like it has some surge
somehow remember the training data a
little bit also this one right here and
there was already a way so this was also
very farsighted so these a to see were
fully connected networks which might be
one of the reasons why worked moderately
well right but the last one was a
convolutional discriminator and AD
convolutional a generator so already
using kind of d convolutions that are
used everywhere today so they are used
in in ganz in whatnot we VA is to
upsample anything if you want to do
pixel wise classification you use d
convolutions so again this this paper
sort of introduced a lot of things that
later that we still use in guns today
now I'm sure D convolutions weren't
invented here but you know we still we
still use them so legit they were the
first gaen paper to use the convolutions
haha yeah they also say we make no claim
that these samples are better than
samples generated by existing methods we
believe that these samples are at least
competitive with the better generative
models in the literature and highlight
the potential of the adversary framework
today this paper would be so rejected
like hey wait you're not better get out
of here
you can't claim you can't claim this
anymore
doesn't work anymore I'm sorry
yours has always has to be better than
everything else nowadays otherwise it's
a it's it's a weak rejecter experimental
evidence doesn't doesn't convince me you
can't simply say something's cool also
already introduced in this paper digits
obtained by linearly interpolating
between coordinates in z space of the
full more like this thing here every
single gantt paper had interpolations in
the like in this in the ganz bike and it
came all came from here so already this
is just like this is a like every gam
paper then had like rows of these like
of these interpolations and I should
know I've I've written the paper on it
and introduced right here who knows if
they hadn't done this yeah I guess it's
it's kind of an obvious thing but still
you know very very cool to see that this
was already done and here ganz compared
to other different methods like deep
direct graphical models generative
auto-encoders
and compared in very many ways so this
is a actually good reference if you want
to learn about these different kinds of
models and they make the claim here that
there are advantages and disadvantages
so disadvantages mainly come with
training these things because you have
to train them in lockstep but then also
the disadvantage is that you don't
have an explicit representation so there
there is no explicit representation of
this probability distribution you never
build the data distribution you can only
sample from it however the advantages
are that Markov chains are never needed
only back prop is used to obtain
gradients no inference is needed during
learning and a wide variety of functions
can be incorporated into the model this
you know I hadn't read this paper in a
while and I just have to laugh nowadays
because you know now all the people are
trying to reintroduce like there are as
many papers like reintroducing Markov
chains into Gans being like oh ma Gans
would be so much better if they had an
MC MC sampler somewhere you're like no
this it the point was to get rid of it
and like no inference is needed during
learning which you know for some of
these other models you actually need an
inference during training right so this
is very very costly and how many models
are there nowadays where it's like oh if
we just do this inference during
training yeah so it it's quite it's
quite funny to see people kind of trying
to to just combine everything with
everything and in the process sort of
reverse reverse
whatever these methods were originally
meant to get rid of now I'm not saying
anything against these methods but it's
just kind of funny yeah so they had a
lot of conclusions and future work they
already say you know conditional Gans
are very easy to do straightforward
learned approximate inference can be
performed by training an auxiliary
network to predict Z given X and this of
course as you know has come you know it
has come to fruit very often early
papers already introduced the D so if
you have the G network producing some
producing an X and then the D network
discriminating that you would also have
like a encoder right here
to produce back the Z noise to give you
the latent encoding sort of like a
variational encoder but not really it's
more like a reverse generator
you know this models nowadays are big by
Gann and things like this that employ
this exact thing that was sort of
predicted right here of course there are
much earlier models also using this as
long as I can remember people have
attempted to bring encoders into Gans
easy they have a bunch of other things
like semi-supervised learning you can
use this to do to do get more data for a
classifier which is also done so a lot
of things here already foresight in this
papers it's pretty cool and the coolest
thing look at that savages Goodfellow
not even using the full eight pages just
not dropping this on the world
absolutely cool
mad respect yeah so yeah this was kind
of my take on general yeah it is
generative adversarial Nets and yeah
you'd please tell me if you like
historic paper overviews it's more kind
of a rant than it really is a paper
explanation but I do enjoy going through
this papers and kind of looking at them
in hindsight all right that was it for
me I wish you nice day bye bye